[Music]
hey folks whoa this is it the new studio
holy hell we're here we're queer it's
loaded up for bear i mean this is very
this table is bigger than my dad's
[ __ ] look at this thing your dad's
[ __ ] is huge huge and it's tasty he's
got a gaping hole yeah yeah especially
after i'm done with him all right we're
starting off hot we haven't wasted any
time in this new studio yeah remember
anal poppers what happened to those anal
poppers i heard about i feel like i
heard about anal poppers every 20
minutes in the 80s the worst kids candy
ever
yeah they pop in your mouth remember
what is it pop rocks pop rocks
the whole thing is you put them in the
soda
that was the whole yeah yeah then you
feel like you're dying or something i
hate it yeah yeah i was never a pop
rocks kid me neither it was it was the
heroine of candy it was too much yeah
that if you did that as a kid you're a
big uh like uh red bull drinker as an
adult yes that's like the type of you're
like yeah right that's true coffee guys
if i see a guy drink a red bull i'm like
all right whatever but if i see a guy
drink a rock star i immediately lose
respect for you really i'm just gonna
come out and say it i'm sorry
and if i see it with an amp it's over
you ever seen amp drink that i think
that came and went and then there was
this bro the white can of rock star is
the whitish trash thing what what's
what's the difference between the white
and the black
well there's a few
the black can is bigger but uh
no though the white one i don't know it
just it's i always see it in like guys
trucks and [ __ ] yeah toothless guys have
the white cam maybe it's a racial thing
i don't know but there it is dude i
haven't seen you forever man oh yeah
it's going to be bad a minute we've been
we backlogged a few in that old studio
because of the move and and here we are
salamanca hey
good to see you there good to be back
having a lo i had a long weekend so
we're doing vodka sodas here
taking it easy taking it easy big i mean
i've been to europe you've recorded
stuff uh we've been on the road lots
happened and we gotta we gotta shout out
to peters for just killing the students
killed this studio man unbelievable
welcome to look we uh yeah i've been
having i mean we were we were in la
together that was pretty epic oh yeah
that's right geez i forgot about that
time has passed yeah we got a overpriced
sushi yeah and then uh not a big fan of
this is it pronounced omakas
i don't know if you know that
i think it's omicron omicron we got
omicron sushi was horrible
give me the chills
myself and you guys are burying the lead
sam was on david letterman yeah oh
that's wow
of course i saw it live i got some pics
yeah i know it was awesome mark was
there just hanging with me to it's funny
i see other comics there they've got
like 20 friends i literally have my
agent and mark
everyone else has like this whole crew
i'm like this is my crew i got norman
and berkowitz is my two but you know but
you know you uh
mark was there like taking my mind off
it before putting me at ease whatever
and then he had to go
host a show so i don't realize mark is
at the late tape until i get a text and
he texts me one of my lines
and i was like oh that's pretty cool
yeah you know but uh
pretty amazing pretty surreal watching
you guys in
[Laughter]
did you ever think you would see this
this video in history this is insane
well dude it's funny you know when you
know how it goes when you're young you
like dream about being interviewed by
letterman right when you were
i mean i would think about game seven
it's game seven yeah one i always wanted
to and then he's off the air and you're
like that'll never happen you know yeah
it is and then uh he was so freaking
cool super cool before the show he
invited every comic who was on this to
just one on one in his green room and he
uh
we're just chatting in his green room
i'm just talking to david letterman and
i'm like i don't know what vibe like you
hear stories you can be a little prickly
you don't know he was the warmest guy
ever i literally walk i walk in he goes
you know so i've watched a lot of your
stuff i'm already like what
wow that's insane and then he goes uh he
goes you know
the the rooftop thing is so resourceful
like so you just kept working he was
he's fascinated by social media i mean
obviously he's
why is he such a great interviewer
there's like a lot of reasons but his
curiosity he's so
curious so he's like you know
uh yeah he was asking me stuff in the
room was like so ha so i don't
understand how you you know you make
money off the the social medias and i
was like well you tore you made the
money on tour and he's like huh because
in his day it was all about like the
sitcom and and
that's how you made the money and you
know i think his whole him like being
like oh so you can circumvent these
gatekeepers now i think he was super
into that he hates management and
keepers oh really yeah yeah i like that
but then he but then he uh at one point
was like do what whatever this interview
is like if you want steamroll me
whatever it takes for you to shine he's
like this is about you i was like
in my head i'm like is he [ __ ] with
me
am i gonna get out there and is he gonna
be like so sam you're a limp dip
olympics [ __ ]
what
the hell is he gonna do no uh that'd be
great if you decided like you know what
[ __ ] this so what was up with that
intern dave
he's like jesus christ what are you
doing no he was you know the first
taping you weren't at the first taping
my agent nearly lost his [ __ ] mind
because i come out and i'm in tight
jeans and my i guess it was like my
phone is poking out
and i go out to do my first bit it hits
pretty hard you know and they yell out i
hear a voice from up top sam and i'm
like is that god what the [ __ ]
who the hell is talking to me sam and
everyone's like confused obviously i'm
like is someone really [ __ ] up my set
right now yeah after my opener hit yeah
you're gonna make me she goes there's a
there's a uh a bulge in your pants i'm
like thank you
[Laughter]
no she goes there's a bulge in your
pants it's your phone i was like all
right so i had to like riff off that she
goes she says is something poking out of
your pants i said yeah it's my [ __ ] and
i gotta laugh thank god all right saving
the moment but she goes you got to
restart the set and i'm kind of like
that is comedy death with my head in my
head i'm kind of like just [ __ ] roll
with it what else i mean it's already
happened what can you do i get off dave
is joking around so letterman goes uh he
goes get the [ __ ] off like playfully you
know get the [ __ ] off
and then he and then he grabs me as i'm
going off he goes i'm so sorry i'm so so
sorry and i said it's cool and i go off
and i'm like all right and i kind of i
do my opener again
exact same joke i have to this time it
hits even harder because the crowd is
[ __ ] mad for me
so they're behind me they're rooting for
you they're rooting for me so i was like
all right honestly it might have been
good that it happened in a weird way
damn that is interesting wow the little
behind the scenes stuff and what a cool
what a mensch to be so nice he knows
what this means you know uh when i was
working with seinfeld he's very generous
he's very nice because he knows that
you're freaking out and that's pretty
pretty uh thoughtful pretty aware yeah
that's nice that he's older even he is
like he doesn't realize how big because
at one point he was like i mean what's
next i'm like dude i'm talking to you
i'm talking to david like this is a big
moment it would be like there was a part
of you where you're like nah this is
this is all right yeah that was a great
ending you had you were so quick on your
feet you were in the zone and uh he goes
uh so how you doing otherwise you're
good you're like how am i doing i'm on
the couch with david [ __ ] letterman
and that went the place went nuts yeah i
mean great way to end it so i know
you're an emotional boy yeah did you
yeah did you feel it at all
uh
yeah i mean i was you know what the
thing was that was a tough weekend for
me because i was literally you know i
taped two shows of that last night that
night on a friday and then the next day
is when i did the beacon so i literally
i'm i had to wake up at like 5 00 a.m
earlier i think it's 4 a.m what a week
to get back to new york to do the beacon
theater that night so i'm
the second i'm out of there i'm like
[ __ ] it muscle relaxer i think i took it
backstage
that's what the muscle relaxer hit so i
can get at least two hours yeah and uh
i've walked sam
home and then i get to the airport i see
christa stefano hey and chris and i and
chris is like you could do it man just
try to get like at least two more hours
of sleep on the flight he's like he's
like amping me up to sleep
and yeah and then i pass out i get up
and he i just as i wake up i just see
chris like yeah
that's great
that's so funny the idea of you taking a
muscle relaxer you pass on the plane
sam's not waking up
oh my god
cancel the bacon
oh man um but very excited i mean that's
a milestone oh it was epic it was so
cool that mark was there with me too
it's it's a good feeling man i was with
you the next night if you're with me the
next night and yeah the big one how can
we hear about the beacon or i mean is
that i mean i gotta hear about it insane
man it's new york city it's i mean you
performed there it's crazy it's uh yeah
it's uh how many times we walked under
that marquee going to stand up new york
or or whatever like oh steely dan oh
carlin oh uh fish or whoever you know
it's always some huge thing or paul
simon yeah and then it's amarillo
crazy crazy i mean it's uh one of the
best i mean it's like he almost can't
picture a better room right it's like
yeah so uh especially for a new yorker
like you like you grew up 10 blocks from
there maybe uh yeah i grew up close to
there so it's pretty it's pretty damn
crazy uh not ten blocks but i mean it
would
that's a yeah it's the upper west side
it's it's iconic it's i mean i'd only
been to one show there i saw the greg
gerolda benefit there which was like
jesus christ talk about like murderous
[ __ ] rose oh yeah it was like a tale
colin quinn
uh seinfeld it was black i mean just
everyone was a murderer
uh
crazy you know i mean the beacon is as
good as it gets man it's the best so
cool and isn't it weird and this is
where i get mushy about comedy but
something about comedy and success and
doing well it all happens in spurts have
you noticed that like
you did letterman at the netflix fest
then the beacon
20 hours later and then a special yeah
can we pace this exactly yeah it hits
you in a point where you're like jesus
christ let me take a [ __ ] breath it
always seems to happen i did a uh
last comic standing
failed then i went and did my half hour
guy had some uh virus from eating ass
and then i went and did my album you
were puffy in the half hour oh was i put
pull that up hold that
i look like you when is it it was just
so bloated i had all these i had this no
no no it's coming to a half hour i'm so
bloaty and fat i look like i've been
floating in a river for three days it
was crazy you got you got that from
eating bud yeah it's a fecal matter
thing damn just fecal matter it's called
h pylori better better to eat ass off
stage than on that's true
uh
the more you know the more you know
yeah just yeah let's see can we just put
up a still yeah is there a still yeah
sure because i am uh i am a mess but
i had to push through you know comedy
central back then there oh look at these
[ __ ] queefs they don't they don't
give you an inch hard to believe they're
[ __ ] failing
oh yeah that does not look like that i'm
deep and this is me with a ton of makeup
on him i'm like i'm like a different guy
you'd be a terrible drag queen yeah
yeah
look at that i remember i didn't know
what i had so i thought i had aids
because wow i just didn't know i was
[ __ ] water my tongue was sheet white
i was uh just sad and anxious and
dehydrated went to the doctor he goes i
don't know what this is let's run some
blood tests i don't know what this is
it's not what you want to hear oh
two weeks later he goes uh are you
sitting down he called me and i'm like
oh god he goes you have h and i was like
i knew
and he goes h pylori it's one pill it's
an antibiotic you're good to go i was
like oh all right jesus christ can we
get a different name for it i know the h
yeah the h i'm just sitting down i mean
it's so such a terrible way to give
someone news yeah are you sitting down
why do we do that yeah
stephen hawking
are you sitting down you know i am
i don't really have an option here
you're sitting down you're paralyzed
dude yeah no the amount of [ __ ] i mean
uh
that happens at once in this biz is
isn't it so you you were in europe
though man you were in london i got to
hear about london i i've never done
comedy in london really that's great but
we didn't exactly ireland together but
i've never done
london london yeah i remember the
ireland was fun too but london it feels
more new yorky it feels there's less
tension there don't you feel like in
america it's like rich versus poor black
versus white men versus women there's
all these movements and everybody's
coming and fighting and canceling and
all this [ __ ] it didn't feel like that
there it's pylori versus comedian i mean
yeah
yeah ass eating but it just felt like
fun and light and it felt like the 90s
again it was weird
um and we did me and lisz and
uh luke monez and ismail luffy all these
guys yeah bruce
have you seen luke mona's characters oh
he is hilarious pull up like the guy who
runs like it's like luke monas
runs into uh god running into like your
girlfriend's friend or something or like
anything like that
or is [ __ ] kendall from succession
impressions or insane oh yeah he's
pomona
yeah yeah no
yeah he's a funny guy he's so funny
underrated he just moved to l.a too oh
did he so he'll probably get in a movie
or something and blow up a great guy do
a great hang in london oh yeah this is a
good one so you're uh casey's boyfriend
lexi you see the joker heather joaquin
three two one jared leto
nice i'm a lego guy sushi do you like
it car horns right
you drive see that
used to be a building there you like
board games i had this idea for trivial
pursuit but kind of porn so they're
close friends i guess that makes us
friends in law
how about a hug
how much the guy like you pull down here
ballpark it for me where'd you go to
school i went to hogwarts just kidding
just a big fan of the harry potter books
i actually did university phoenix not
online
but at the time i was told that it was a
real school take your time we're good
i'm getting to know uh
[Music]
what's your favorite kind of weather
what do you think that is huh
2.6 million views or something like that
and this is like the
when your girlfriend runs into her
friend and you're stuck with the other
boyfriend oh that's great great premise
yeah i'm actually on an adult mock trial
team so what did it surprise you to
learn that i am 61 years old
so random yeah he's funny too stand up
is great uh cool guy we hung out
everybody would get breakfast in the
morning so i got to break down london
break it down dude we were out there
doing a game show
and they pay you well they fly out first
class they put you up in this insane
hotel people have top hats and [ __ ] and
they press your coats you know it's one
of these places and whispering your
fiance that's the [ __ ] monopoly guy
yeah
[Laughter]
it was like a little downton abbey type
[ __ ] but
jess high end high-end and me and list
are like this is insane look how nice
they're treating us wow the money's good
you're on the show with list yeah he was
there like a few days before me so he
did an episode then i flew in and i was
like hey we're here oh my god london
here we go and then he's like have you
done any work yet for the show i was
like i haven't even opened the packet
and he's like you're [ __ ] what's the
premise for the show it's kind of like
at midnight it's these british panel
shows are huge there like they're they
mock the week another one the guy who
made this did last i'll not laska what's
that one called whose line is it anyway
oh wow so he's like a big swinging
producer dick
and this was a big show 300 people in
the audience huge set dulce sloan hosted
it chanel ali we're all hanging out but
it was a big production and i was just
like yeah we're funny guys we'll go in
we'll zing and zang
we got our ass kicked these british guys
are on the show they're so quick this is
this is their whole life so it's america
versus versus england do you feel
patriotic
a little yeah but we sucked so i was
like maybe i'll move here you know long
live the queen
is the show good
well i don't want to trash the show but
it i felt like the funniest parts about
you they took away i hate that isn't
that bad yeah yeah like it was a lot of
puns like they go what's a meat and a
book and you go
man harry pot roast
and you're like what am i doing i got an
act i'm selling tickets now what the
[ __ ] am i doing here but you know you
got to write i also don't think i'm
never like i'm not a big pun guy like
look there's a place for me but sure but
they're easier than jokes yeah and it's
not it doesn't elicit a lot of laughter
you kind of go ah so they're more just
like applauding that you that you're
clever yeah yes very clever and look
that people said some funny jokes these
british guys were amazing they were
quick as [ __ ] but they live for this
this is like their like the way we write
jokes they write panel jokes
and
i stayed up all night one night because
it was so embarrassing how bad i bombed
because how much i wasn't prepared so i
stayed up all night the next night i
brought i brought my gal out to london
she was like what are we doing today i'm
like i'm writing i'm in the hotel right
i'm in the business center writing
brutal so i got my ass kicked on this
show so that's it
no it's on the cw i think but you're not
happy with it no but i mean it's
it's a pun show so it's not the end of
the world but damn ooh it was rough
damn i guess it's on me because i was
like oh i'll just go out to london i did
some sets at night and get drunk i was
drinking at five at the pubs all day but
man that show kicked my ass what were
they cover testing you the whole time
the whole thing with the coveted test
see internationally that would stress me
out so much because you even if you get
like a false positive now i'm just like
stuck in [ __ ] london yeah and they
hit you every day multiple times a day
wardrobe you know gotta get your packet
printed send in your packet it was a lot
of work
and i had no idea but london was awesome
did sets at night the crowds there are
white hot joe list listed the comedy
store we went and watched him i mean we
had a blast
what are you pulling up sally oh it's my
impression of mark in london
i tried everything
i was pulling out old tweets old jokes
everything just trying to get a laugh
yeah no i hear you but still a trip to
london i brought the lady i bought her
ticket but i was in first class she was
in the last
and final row of an international flight
up on the bathroom wall wow and i was
like oh i felt so bad but i went back
and gave my pillow i'd get i'd get
first-class food i'd walk it back to her
just out of guilt that's hilarious yeah
i feel like i was up in the the hamptons
and she was like and uh you know
bed-stuy like in weekend at bernie's or
just chilling on the roof remember that
oh yeah a hot summer roof
brutal but uh we had a blast and the pub
culture there is so cool i love an old
pub oh it's the best five o'clock
they're all filled out with people who
got off work they're drinking they're
socializing i feel like they look at
their phones less there they talk more
there they interact more yeah just felt
happier there that was a germany oh here
he goes oh sorry
i was in germany in berlin and i like
walked into this bar total pub scene and
i was like to the bartender i was like
can i get the wi-fi he's like go enjoy
your life go sit outside oh you didn't
give it to me where was this in berlin
wow
they're better than us
go enjoy your life maybe it's for like a
work thing you don't [ __ ] know he was
saying if you're here you're obviously
on vacation what are you doing on your
[ __ ] phone
yeah i don't like it
i got a point but he he's got a point
but guess what like tell me the [ __ ]
wi-fi yeah yeah guess who doesn't like
germany
[Laughter]
still haven't forgiven them
the wi-fi offense slightly less yeah
yeah almost problematic but yeah
first they killed six million jews now
they won't [ __ ] give up the wi-fi
code it never ends with these [ __ ]
people
what was the bar called goebbels
he's stoned british talk show uh mark
yeah but uh
go ahead i said richard gere put a
gerbils up as that there we go all right
[Laughter]
i'll tweet it
i'll sell that to a british comic
but it shows they're all and we're we're
like hot [ __ ] in london i was going to
comedy clubs uh like hey i'm mark
normally like oh what mark norman
you want to go on all that [ __ ] so
that's really nice yeah yeah so you can
clean up all right hey man
just taped the special in chicago
pretty happy oh let's hear about it you
did something a little different than
seven shows we did seven shows
seven shows yeah i know i'm a [ __ ]
idiot i couldn't help myself i will you
get good moments man but i'll tell you
the problem with taping seven shows is
like
there's a new person that comes to hang
out at the show every night of the four
nights of taping yeah you're getting
drunk every night
yeah i mean i i'm at the den in chicago
i go in there you know 20 bottles of
natural wine in my green room oh i've
got whiskey in there i'm like yeah
there's there's no wine left by the end
of the week we're [ __ ] pounding this
[ __ ] gee who who stocked the green room
uh hitchins
holy [ __ ] that's a lot of booze quick
interjection i was at the comedy
connection in providence yeah and you
signed the wall yeah it says great club
bad wine oh yeah yeah yeah well they
bought me some wine back there with some
horde i'm not drinking this [ __ ] i'm no
snob but this is going to kill me the
next day
you got to be careful with the wine with
the hangovers true true so you have
natural wine there stocked natural wine
the hangover's not as bad i'm in a hotel
with vito we got a good raid in this
hotel there's a sauna in the hotel so
every day we wake up we [ __ ] sweat
out the booze hell yeah nice little nice
little routine yeah it works too man
that that sauna [ __ ] works that sonic
[ __ ] is nice it really is i there's like
a lot of health benefits to sauna if i
ever hit it big i'd do the sauna and the
the house
really over steam
you know [ __ ] crazy you go sauna over
steam
i'm a steam guy i don't know what the
difference is steam is wet heat sauna's
dry heat oh i think that's the
difference right the sauna smells like
got wood and stuff inside
rocks
is that the sauna no dry heat's what i
called my eggs
but uh yeah it's all smoky and steamy
yeah maybe i do like sauna no maybe i
like steam steam is better i now i think
you have to stay in a steam as long
either you kind of just get the
okay full steam ahead
good to know but i would do it i would
do if i was a millionaire i'd go steam
room in the house i think you're doing
you're close buddy wow i think that's a
big operation you got to break walls
down and pipes and plumbing
i don't know it's going to happen but it
feels like a heavy duty hour but you get
like you know the size of maybe two
phone booths just sit in that thing love
it that's all you need that's all you
need yeah oh by the way last phone booth
was taken out of manhattan last week
really yeah it was like a big deal damn
no more phone booths not one first they
come for the phone booths then they're
coming for the yellow cabs yeah ready
begun that's right these [ __ ]
these uber [ __ ] it's not progress
yellow cabs are good bring bring back
the kids
we all hate it i mean i've done it on
this pod too many times i've complained
about it too much but man it's like it's
depressing as hell to watch these old
movies and yellow cabs everywhere and
it's like it's gonna look like a horse
and carriage soon yeah yeah you know
it's terrible i want to get back to
chicago though oh yeah sorry so seven
shows when did you know you had it
third show oh wow i i mean we
we got there wednesday and i'll say this
wednesday was probably the worst crowd
which is but i also was probably the
worst i was all week because you're just
trying to the first tape you're like let
me just get the jokes so then you're not
really yourself and then once you have
it like
then the second show man we pretty much
got it on the thursday early show i was
like yeah i got the jokes to hit and
then the late show i'm loose because i
felt confident and that's when i'm like
oh no we really got the jokes to hit you
know so then you start riffing you start
[ __ ] around start doing crowd work i
started kind of
making you know going off the cuff a
little having fun and then when you're
loose you're like oh that's you that's
so that was once you hit the third one
then you're like all right now i can
really wednesday i might have had like a
couple drinks and then like thursday i'm
like i'm drinking nice i think you're
gonna cut together seven or you're gonna
be like this is the main one and we're
gonna use pieces from there might be
like a moment in each show that's funny
but like yeah because you kind of try to
differentiate it a little bit just to
stay engaged because you know you know
the feeling you just get bored with the
act oh yeah you get really bored with
the jokes you've been telling them on
tour for so long that you're just kind
of like i just want to just want to [ __ ]
around dude yeah that must have cost you
a fortune how are you going to recoup uh
we'll see i mean seven shows i know that
costs a lot of money calm down you got
to think he's making money
no i am yeah i know i mean i made money
shooting
tickets and we never know where the
special end up so
history stay tuned
very exciting uh but yeah no
everything's uh don't you feel good
because we've all recorded a show where
you're like i don't know how that was
and then you you know comedy central or
some weirdo group is editing it so
you're like i hope they edit that right
yeah but this is all you
you're good you feel good about it i
feel pretty good yeah i think it'll i
think it'll be good but then then you
have the problem where you're like why
not i got to write a new act well that's
a whole another background it's [ __ ]
hard hard to keep writing new
new jokes it keeps you humble though
cause
you notice the comics that keep burning
[ __ ] you can't like yourself too much
because you're not going up and killing
as much as people that keep kind of
playing the hit so you got that right
you go up there and you start you get
humble pretty easily yeah this is why
these old-timers just do the same act
for you know 20 years cause if they try
a new thing and it bombs now people are
like i thought you were a legend
so it's hard it's a hard process it's a
tightrope
yeah to work that new [ __ ] out
yeah any any wrecks well wait i gotta
ask hold on before you
if this comes out what august september
yeah so you still got
a hot two three months today i hope at
least two months couch the new [ __ ] with
some of the old stuff on the road
yeah
i'm taking a few days off
in july i'm going to go to a resort and
just chill out and just
yeah
a resort that's nice
no good for you
[Laughter]
you don't hear about resort you go in a
resort of here well i don't do it much
but i've i've been told by a lot of
people that you never take a break you
need to do something where you recharge
so i'm going to give it a shot and my
friend uh my buddy chase is going to
come join me the last couple night we're
just going to do it up we'll do [ __ ]
well you know probably drank we'll
try to have some fun so all right well
this is a weird way to come out of the
closet you're going up to a resort with
this guy chase so i've never heard of i
was sick of the chase
i thought i'd bring my own no yeah
uh
resorting to homophobe
[Laughter]
save that for the british shows yeah
it's really
shaken
uh yeah no man any any recommendations
uh well let's see i got more peeves than
rex they hit me with a [ __ ] pig
it's been a while okay
oh i did have a wreck i did see top gun
but we'll talk about that uh is it good
well i'll just say i'll i'll recommend
it it's it's got a lot of cheese on it
you know like
he gets uh he has a problem with one of
the other cadets and the other cadets
like a good-looking over-the-top cocky
guy
and then the the guy with glasses is the
nerd and the dweeb and everybody it's
just so uh
cartoony yeah everything's very trophy a
lot of tropes yeah i'll just say that a
lot of tropes
but
i had high tropes for this one yeah
england
england
um
we need to play that british music oh
sorry when the queen walks out every
time we do a pun can we get that sound
effect you know that the changing of the
guards or whatever
the buckingham palace [ __ ]
all right that joke princess died
we're back
what uh yeah but yeah top gun is fun
yeah i saw with my lady she was just
like this is so cheesy but by the end of
it we're both fist pumping yeah you know
i had like a little american flag pin
and uh it was a good time i mean say
what you want but like tom cruise is
kind of like the last
of the movie star type guy you know and
obviously there's others but he really
is like an old school
what the oh that's queen no i need the
british [ __ ] jesus christ what the hell
are we doing
you just bankrupt the [ __ ] new studio
what the hell are you doing
sam's gonna be playing that at the
resort
uh
what uh yeah i i got it aids h pylori
got h pylori
we uh
yeah so go see top gun it's fine i gotta
i got a movie rack for you okay and i
think solo queues will will back me up
on this hustle on netflix
sandler's new movie i'm excited
tailor-made for someone like me yes
really it was it's just like a total
movie like a basketball it's like it's
like my friend described it as like nba
2k my player mode if if that were a
movie oh you're like rising the ranks
it's awesome sandler [ __ ] kills it
really kills it he can act man once i
saw punch drunk love i was like this
guy's a solid actor yeah oh it's it's so
good the guy who plays the the star uh
juancho hernan gomez he's he's in the
league he's like you know he had like
one good nba season his brother played
for the knicks actually willie hernan
gomez and i loved willy he was a brick
wall but uh
you know
they're both from spain here's the
trailer i'd sort of describe it as
jerry maguire meets a great armor all
commercial
or under armour commercial all right all
right
oh philly huh
because if you don't let's not even
bother let's not open that door they're
just going to slam it right in our face
wow producers lebron james i love this
game i love this game and dude that's
kenny smith a lot of players are actors
in it anthony edwards he's a great young
player he's funny as hell in the movie
he's really good
he's a great young player
obsession is going to be talent every
time
wow
is this why sandler's been bawling a lot
okay he can play
let's face it it's you again queen
latifa is a love interest oh she's great
great always great
lesbian
you have to think i am the best guy out
there
but also you're watching this i'm like
dude if sandler was motivating me i
could i could become pretty good at
hoops yeah yeah totally he just you buy
him as a motivator right
yeah dude it's it's an awesome movie
it's just a it's just a really fun it's
a really good sports movie all right i
love a good sports movie i i dug it i
was watching on the road i was like oh
this is this is putting me in a good
place
i'm down i will watch it would the lady
like it or would she hate it yeah it's
great i told my agent to watch it and
she uh she and her boyfriend are like
that she's texting me she's like this is
amazing i was like
it's awesome
and it's like sandler just [ __ ] he
rules man good for sandler man i mean
you know snl great comic to snl to
household name to then putting out some
jack and jills and clicks and whatnot
but
i thought click was was pretty
solid you're the one they all do well
yeah yeah that's true that's true yeah
one on netflix that was pretty wild well
dude you know when you make like 30
movies yeah you're not gonna hit a home
run on every one of them he had an epic
run you know epic run but he's still
running he's what i'm saying like he's
just reinventing uncut gems this great
stand-up special was fun the lady was
good
i liked it yeah so
good for him yeah stay with it keep
going
you're telling adam sandler to stay with
it yeah yeah condescending [ __ ] i'm just
this is what happens when you go to
england you go no
stay with it mate
oh boy they're passive aggressive ninjas
in england oh my god amazing well i
asked one guy i was like excuse me sir
which way is oxford street he's like you
got a smartphone do you
like oh jesus
thanks nigel
that guy just zinged me i didn't realize
until 20 minutes later i got a pee for
you and this one yeah this is a good
peeve cause it comes back to me as these
often do where i get annoyed then it
kind of turns into my fault
the you ever have the train coming and
then the guy in front of you just takes
their sweet [ __ ] time they block you
off for the turnstile so you can't get
out oh yeah this prick is like he's like
let me tell you i'm like that's the
train [ __ ] move
so i'm getting annoyed so i just zing
right in front of him i cut him off i do
the old flippity flop and then and then
my uh i'm doing the you know yeah you
know what's coming tap yeah the tap it
won't read it so now i now you're him
but you and now i'm him yeah you turned
me into you but your shittiness made me
shitty i caught shittiness interesting
hurt people hurt people yeah wow but at
least you're trying at least i'm trying
this guy's like fiddling with [ __ ] yeah
uh but yeah if the train is coming i
mean you gotta hustle that's just uh
yeah that's just the rule oh you have
the friend too i've had friends who are
like you know i one time i made it
through a late night you made it through
my friend yells out go on without me
because he couldn't get through that's a
real friend that's a friend yeah do you
want to be living with alex
i would never yeah
tell the world my story
that's when you hold the door that's
what you're doing and then everyone
hates you for a different reason yeah
but you can deal with them hating it
this is a friend here
but yeah i'm with you i would have
jumped it at that point i mean come on
if the trains that you cannot miss the
train i've had girls on dates where
they're like oh
a tampon oh a luna bar oh a nuva ring
and i'm like what are you doing the
train's here get that purse going this
is mark's chance to ditch them he just
hops over like later
yeah she was like don't wait for me i
was like you got it
hey folks we might be drunk as sponsored
by better help online therapy many
people are burned out they don't even
know it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless trapped attachment
fatigue or more
we like therapy we go to the same guy
changes our lives you gotta do it the
bags are piling up you gotta take out
the mental and emotional garbage folks
and this is an easy way to do it we
associate burnout with work but that's
not the only cause dead
most things in life can lead us
burned out and better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
we love it i was a mess still am a mess
but at least now i know it yeah
therapy's good man huge
yeah why not it's good for you if you'll
feel better so maybe it's your mother
probably is
most likely your parents that's 80
chance maybe a priest
better help his cousin or rabbi or rabbi
or
what's the other one
what's the muslim guy
ah
better help his customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's more
affordable than in person
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours holy hell
you drunks out there get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
drunk that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com
slash drunk
get on it
we might be drunk is brought to you by
manscaped thanks to manscaped everything
goes down the drain including my career
try their new platinum package it's like
their greatest hits collection the
lawnmower 4.0 has a special blade so you
don't cut yourself and has spotlight to
shave in the dark plus it's waterproof
the weed whacker nose and ear hair
trimmer keeps your holes safe while you
clean up got to keep those holes safe
folks why while their crop preserver and
crop reviver keep you fresh
south of the equator the ultra premium
collection with body wash two in one
shampoo and conditioner and deodorant
help you smell good from head to toe get
20 off and free shipping with the code
drunk at manscape.com that's 20 off free
shipping with the code drunk at
manscape.com
your balls will thank you and so your
lady or man
yes
hey hey with all the jargon flying
around it can be hard to figure out how
to start investing get your money right
getting your money right is easier with
sofi the first investing platform to
offer stocks etfs automated investing
cryptocurrency all in one app
we don't know what the hell we're doing
the dollar is worthless inflation's
going up i don't know if it's putin if
it's biden if it's cardi b
lizzo i can't keep up whether you're
eager to get started with investing or
you're ready
to find out the ropes sofi has your back
no commissions on trading stocks etfs
and no account fees or hidden fees
use fractional shares that start as low
as five dollars to buy brand name stocks
hey that's good
sofi's complimentary financial planners
are ready to help with any questions
whether you're stuck on where to start
or help deciding what to do next save
for your retirement with traditional
roth and sep iras
set your own investment goals
from saving for retirement to building
up
a down payment so true this stuff is
complicated
i'm slow i'm simple i don't know what
i'm doing i'd like to get involved so
this is
taylor made for me cut through the jar
yes are you investing
a little yeah yeah i got a guy who does
it for me i don't know what i'm doing
same i don't have time to learn this
stuff we're comedians and that's what
sofi is for cut through the jargon and
make investing easier with so five visit
sofi.com
drunk to learn how you can win up to a
thousand dollars in stock when you open
an account wow that's s o f i dot com
slash drunk brokerage and active
investing products offered through sofi
securities llc member
finra sipike
f-i-n-r-a-s-i-p-c
clueless
you know us and we look at plenty of
[ __ ] online we don't want other people
to know about
and we'll let you guess what that is
most you're probably thinking why don't
you just use incognito mode incognito
mode doesn't hide your activity and
cleaning your browser history doesn't
erase it your internet service provider
can still see every single website you
visited uh-oh
that's why even when i'm at home i never
go online without using my express vpn
expressvpn reroutes your internet
connection through their secure servers
so your isp can't see the sites you
visit i mean i'm doing this the second i
get home most of the time i don't even
realize how i have expressvpn on it runs
seamlessly in the background and is easy
to use all you have to do is tap one
button and you're protected expressvpn
works across all your devices phones
computers even your smart tv so there's
no excuse not to use it i love how easy
expressvpn is to use on my phone protect
your online activity today with the vpn
rated number one by business insider
visit our exclusive link
expressvpn.comdrunk
and you can get an extra three month
free on a one year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
drunk expressvpn.com
to learn more oh yeah
don't wait for me when i first started
dating stacy
she's not from new york and i am and you
know how you walk on the train you kind
of like stay there until someone pushes
you a little bit
so i led
and i was expecting her to push you know
to push me in and she didn't and the
door was closed and she was on the
outside and i was on the inside
and i turned around and she's like this
oh
i know she should have just left me then
like yes this train leaves never sees me
again did you have phones at the time no
no this is like 2005.
yeah i just lost her yeah i was like
i'll see you damn
whoa man that's when you have to
communicate like meet you at the next
stop or something like that next stop
damn that's old school wow would you get
in a phone booth after that
collect caller yeah
by the way i went to a phone booth like
i don't know 2009 i saw one and i was
like oh phone booth and i got in it just
smelled like piss and miscarriage i was
like all right [ __ ] i'm good
it was like this nostalgic cool moment
that it just was ruined by
some hobo i definitely pissed in a lot
of phone booths there you go when you
get drunk you just when you're young
you're like no one this is a place to
pee
all right i got i got so many peeves i
can't save some i'll save some but yeah
hit me with another all right how about
this guy
i met this kid and he was like a young
comic and we were hanging out and he was
nervous he was just he's just anxiety
riddled you're gonna break so many young
comics who listens to this heart i'm not
gonna say he's done this before where
he's like this comic from this weekend
it was luke bonus
this guy sweet kid he's probably like 20
or 21. and he was just kind of a keyed
up squirrely kid and he would do a thing
that would drive me crazy where he would
say huh after every question just to buy
him some time to think about it so like
asked me a question uh how was england
huh
oh england was good england was good he
just needs a little more time you know
but it was driving me crazy because i
would go i was england and repeat it and
then now i'm repeating it and then he's
answering it so now we're butting up
against each other so like asked me like
three questions in a row
um where did you stay in england huh
oh i stayed at the lane
what no where the show was good huh
where the show is going shows are great
shows were great he's killed the rhythm
now yes the rhythm is the rhythm is gone
yeah the rhythm is going to get you and
this guy was i couldn't get a
conversation going and then even if i
tried i didn't want to because it was so
frustrating with the huh huh what's her
name we sing that again which one gloria
stefan yeah dude tom mccaffrey you know
that joke no great joke he used to say
like when people were like that song
changed my life he's like yeah that
never has happened ever it's never like
i used to be uh i used to work in a deli
now i'm a navy seal all thanks to uh
gloria stefan's rhythm is gonna get you
i don't know that joke i'm [ __ ] up
the algorithm here oh [ __ ] this is my uh
that's my new orleans this is the song
called huh
that's right juvenile huh
but he's saying it he's every sentence
ends in uh-huh yeah no way let me let me
ask mark another question this is this
is a woman in 2015. do you have h pylori
dude thanks to you
that's what i wrote on the green room
wall great club badass
eating butt dude you're reckless well i
just got out of like a 12-year
relationship and eating ass was like the
new thing so i just like i'm in i'd put
a napkin in my shirt i'd bring a fork
and a knife and i'd go to town oh yeah
gotta do it you know who does that huh
thing is rich voss huh yeah
but then
but then he comes back right after he
doesn't make you say the question again
he says huh and then he [ __ ] jabs you
yeah he needs just one millisecond to
yeah
yeah
you know what another big one is uh when
they go
uh ask me a question somebody what was
that
well yeah give me like a like a like a
full scene where are you from mark who
me
i said your [ __ ] name but they just
need me i said mark yeah what the hell
who me no we're in a phone booth
together yeah i'm talking to you my
dick's out you're talking to me
huh yeah who me yes yes you yeah that
was the original taxi driver you talking
to me then he's look in the mirror who
me
[Laughter]
yeah
all right
so yeah that that drove me [ __ ] crazy
and then just to be in a green room
every weekend and i started doing it to
him and he'd go uh
so uh i'd go so where are you from and
then he he'd go huh and i'd say huh at
the same time and he didn't like that
wow yeah but i just couldn't take it
anymore what uh should we do some news
hell yeah please what do we have for the
news
cronkite
what do we have all right
we have do you want to read them or you
read them all right are you lapelled
okay just checking i didn't see a
microphone dave lapel let's go
uh urine
trouble no more massachusetts bay
transportation authority hopes with a
new program to tackle public urination
in the system's
elevators with technology the
mbta
which services boston and the
surrounding area is launching a pilot
program this summer in which urine
detection sensors will be placed in four
downtown
in
elevators
whoa
the sensor alerts the transit
ambassadors
that's a bit lofty
a guy with a broom
i'm a transit ambassador like you get
your biggest bucket yeah you pick up
urine you [ __ ] what do you do for
work i'm an mta diplomat all right i
clean [ __ ] okay the transit ambassador
will dispatch a cleaning crew
wow
that's a rough one i'm glad this wasn't
on my mattress as a child
straight to prison
what a weird use of technology
i know you you can sense piss
yeah
yeah we got i feel like our priorities
are out of whack like we have hungry
people we have filthy water we have all
this [ __ ] going on and we're working on
this well i think it [ __ ] up i think it
kills a i think it kills a
elevator like you can it's not just the
smell it can like badly damage the oh
i mean the smell sucks i think i mean if
they what they really should do is have
like a low yield shock that comes up
with the pissed into your penis
no
just why not
you shouldn't be pissing in there in the
first i don't think i don't think that's
okay i don't think i think that's way
worse than pissing on the thing really
getting a shock on your dick how many
times did you piss in an elevator after
that i know i know but
what are we trying to curb you're using
violence on someone's dick yeah what is
this all right lorena bobbitt jesus
christ
yeah also you're gonna be hooking up
with a girl later you're like watch out
for my dick she's like herpes like
elevator
pissed well also like can you imagine
peeing in an elevator an alarm goes off
oh that's [ __ ] terrifying
yeah you know what else wasn't wasn't a
picnic was uh back when you were a kid
and they started putting that liquid
[ __ ] in the water of a pool where when
you pee it would turn green you remember
that yeah it was some chemical really i
think that was i think that was a wives
tale to get kids not to do it oh well i
was a big pool pier and uh who was never
changed oh you were too every kid all
right i mean that's the thing whenever i
see kids in a pool on the road i'm like
[ __ ] oh yeah it's just a it's a toilet
yeah
it's a giant toilet it is it's uh i mean
uh
i definitely have peed on the street
like a lot in my life but it's also like
you have to think if you're peeing in an
elevator like that's usually you're
either pissed drunk or it's like
an only or last resort yeah yeah right
because like
you're drunk you're homeless you can't
find somewhere to pee
yeah i don't know i remember i got
handcuffed i used to do a bit about this
i got handcuffed by a cop once i was
shit-facing you guys you were not
seriously peeing on the street and i
said no i'm doing it ironically
i got handcuffed and he let me go but
yeah i've gotten caught three times
peeing in public it's a bummer but
you know my street i live on a little
little weird kind of alley type street
yeah everybody pisses on my street
you know
mcdougall's right there it's like a
party bar strip yeah so i live a block
off that so my street is just pissed
central and i can see them from my
apartment i'll like tap my lady like
got another one you can't help it you
get it once it was like an alley so you
kind of yeah i i walk down your block
and i'm like i do have to go yeah you
see it's tough electrical shock
all right i don't i'm not with the
electric shock i'm not i don't think
that's okay
how about pouring a glass of water on
them
in a glass of water pouring lots of piss
on them yeah oh ah what's good for you
this is good for the gander
all right okay
never heard the expression used like
that before pour some piano it's good
for you
that's a good move
so we have another one here yeah uh in
the wiggle of a nose
a man partially covered the bewitched
statue in salem with red paint witnesses
called police around 5 pm monday to
report someone spray painting the bronze
statue captain so-and-so she got carried
yeah
the statue depicts elizabeth montgomery
as lead character of samantha stevens
from the 1966 com bewitched
sitting on a broomstick in runway i did
not know so this is crazy that be
bewitched in salem well that's funny
i think they knew what they were doing
that's a good yeah no i think they shot
some of it in
uh salem but that's crazy that's salem
witch trials right yeah
but then a guy is still upset about
witches apparently oh maybe i don't do
you think he's really mad about the show
i think he's probably just saw a statue
he wanted to vandalize that'd be
hilarious if he was like a he just hated
old school tv he's like next we're gonna
egg to leave it to beaver house
uh yeah i don't know this is very
strange but
half red this is a this is very symbolic
yeah something's up thumbs up it's also
like satanic
it's satanic and also it's it's salem
like this is where witches were hung
witches they weren't real witches but
they were they were killed yeah in uh
and now it's like it's if they put a
[ __ ]
larry david statue in auschwitz or
something right
right good point it's weird
that's true you put it right in the
heart of it
interesting
all right we got one more here boy
people are weird people have too much
time on their hands
this is from charlotte north carolina
federal authorities say a man has been
arrested in charlotte north carolina
after he was stopped in the city's
airport with more than 23 pounds
of cocaine concealed in seat cushions of
a motorized wheelchair
wheelchair back to hawking hawkins going
quick today talk about a jazzy
this guy's a real rascal
that's 23 pound is a lot that is a lot
so they ripped apart the the wheelchair
and they found
they better i bet they were thrilled
that there was cocaine in there because
they were like wow that would that must
have been if you rip apart someone's
wheelchair yeah
was he really uh looking handicapped no
way oh here it is
whoa
do you think he was actually handicapped
do you think it was just a
a move
i think it was a move i think it's a
move
because and how did they find was it a
dog sniff because you see a guy in that
wheelchair you're gonna let him roll
right by you i don't think that's an
international airport i'd be surprised
if there were dogs in there froze there
clt definitely an international it is oh
yeah charlotte it's a huge airport
yeah is that the one with the rocking
chairs
the rocking chairs in there because
they're like we're southern i think so i
think it is charlotte uh by the way the
clt i always think of [ __ ] when i booked
that
i couldn't find the airport
oh [ __ ] this is a weird one yeah what is
going on with bieber so there's a bigger
story here that's not this oh here it is
bieber's uh justin bieber said oh well
his face has been paralyzed whoa and his
cancelling shows until he gets better
half paralyzed excuse me half paralysis
it's it's from the ramsey something
ramsay what you're gonna tell it
let me see
i can't smile on this side of my face
wait pause it to say this
i think my ex-girlfriend had that on
both sides of her face oh god smile
so there's full paralysis in the side of
my face oh man justin bieber gives us
crazy right
yeah well he's super young to have this
what is it
what's it called ramsay something what's
it
ramsey hunt dude well this usually hits
people who are like over 60 at least
he's he's in his 20s i think yeah yeah
is it a stressing cocaine thing it's an
ear virus that then [ __ ] up your face
yeah holy [ __ ] so anyone could get it if
it's a virus yeah you can catch it yeah
h by laurie
also a virus
but dude that's like that's like if like
you got that and then it [ __ ] your
dick up right you know what i mean like
that's crazy that it's it so you get it
goes in your ear and then [ __ ] your
face up i mean that's crazy and half
paralyzed is it a recovery process i'm
sure i think it's yeah i think you can
recover but it's i mean it's he canceled
a tour i mean i think about how much
money we lose if we cancel a tour and
then think about what justin bieber just
lost multi multi-million crazy crazy
that's that's terrible yeah i think
he'll come out swinging he's religious
too so what does that say about god
where's your god now beeps
i guess you're not a believer
[Laughter]
okay we've got some uh hot salem witch
news
salem witch yeah
yeah uh three centuries after being
convicted of hocus pocus
uh the last salem which quotes has been
officially pardoned by the state of
massachusetts elizabeth johnson jr found
herself in hot water
in 1693
when puritans caught up in the salem
witchcraft came knocking on her door at
only 22 years old johnson jones johnson
joined dozens of others including her
own mother on the chopping block as a
frenzy of folks declared them witches
and sentenced them to death
yeah i mean that's i don't know about
the apollo i mean why do you have to do
a pardon three centuries later like
clearly you weren't a part of this
i know it's such a again a waste of time
it's all symbolic i guess it's symbolic
but
it's next
[Laughter]
you mean getting pardoned no no getting
burned
i think that's already happened yeah
that's true
it's a witch hunt folks
that's that's the modern-day witch yeah
i think people get annoyed with their
town or you know like back to germany
they're like super obsessed with feeling
bad about the holocaust you can't make a
holocaust joke you can't make a jew joke
it's illegal to make a jew joke in
germany
so people just get arrested on stage if
you do they get arrested
in a bar you get arrested who's watching
i think somebody could report you can't
well jews can make a jew joke
i don't know i bet no one will laugh
i think it's just two like oh [ __ ] the
guilt i feel like that's the least you
can let us make jokes i agree yeah yeah
i mean that'd be great if they're like
these are that you're on trial for
making a jew joke in germany how [ __ ]
ironic would that be
yeah i know right you get the gas
chamber i'm sorry
yeah but i was about to say the jews
live in germany but then i realized yeah
black people live here oh do jews live
in germany absolutely that was a dumb
question but just
take it out loud
what uh all right i don't know if i'd
want to live in germany or maybe you
would because anybody everybody would be
really nice to you
if you're jewish
yeah it's probably just fine now
probably fine oh yeah should we you want
to do we have a camera on that matt the
bodega i get i get it
whoa baby what's that what's that you're
holding mark oh
how do you like them apples huh
here's h by laurie
here we go bodega cat it's here
is this the unveiling of the name and
everything oh yeah the whole kitten
caboodle the bottle the label
it looks good man so what happened chris
uh brought you one in chicago yeah very
exciting he showed up so christopher who
were in business with for bodega cat
uh not only did he bring bodega cat he
bought he brought uh
a talisker 35 year old bottle to my
taping let's just say that did not make
it through the first night wow we killed
that pretty quickly incredible petey
scotch
and then i mean this is it's really
great whiskey i can't wait for you to
try it it's really
yeah i'm drinking with people my agent
you know she's drinking it and she goes
i never have drank whiskey straight up
that i could handle this is so smooth
i'm gonna crack it open no it's great we
will crack it open we're gonna crack it
open i just want to pour some in here
right now pour some in all right i don't
know if i could yeah
very exciting yeah remember i mean for
the folks at home we tried what nine ten
ten samples of rye and this was the
winner for sure yeah
ah
that's [ __ ] good this is by the way
our normal [ __ ] will be uh
i think 45
this is 50
hell yeah for some reason i don't know
why i think it's like
take a little pull off that ah 12 years
sober down the drain
bodega cat we might be drunk i was with
gary veeder who doesn't normally
drink but for my special week he was
drinking every night
he's a fun drunk too he's a fun drunk
and he was he was another one he was
like this is [ __ ] good bodega cat you
know what bodega head's a great name for
this is because like when you're in a
bodega and the cat shows up you're
[ __ ] happy you got that right there's
something about that cat popping and we
were like oh yes you're never bummed to
see a bodega cat no i always pet it they
sleep on the bread they're adorable and
they keep the mice out people in
nebraska don't know what a bodega is or
a bodega cat it's like a little corner
store and then what is the bodega i
think they have bodegas all over the
country yeah it's a corn store
convenience store uh usually
run by a normal guy not a corporation
and they always have a cat in there
because they kill the mice and they keep
the store friendly and and they're
usually open late that's the perk of the
stores you can pop in there in new york
at least you can pop in there at like
midnight and get a get a hoagie you got
that right yeah you get a little you
know what's your late-night chick like
sandwich what do you get i go uh turkey
on a roll
love it love it
lettuce tomato mayo onion
salt pepper vinegar any pickle or no
i'll do pickles
and i'll do cheese i'll [ __ ] with a
jalapeno too oh yes
hey hey
this is it gang
i never thought i'd be here i have
people on the road when's the whisper
it's really [ __ ] good i mean it's
really quality man you want to take a
sip uh i don't drink hard alcohol i mean
but this is i'll make an exception
just a smooch just take a kiss yeah you
want to yeah take some remarks right
there just just kiss it just let it hit
the lip give it a kiss just the tip dude
yeah just suck that [ __ ] butt sorry
go ahead oh it smells good all right
it's like notes of caramel and vanilla
and yeah it's like it really is it's
really good
yeah i don't like that stuff and that's
good
all right
it doesn't have that burn that like i
normally feel that's really good you can
go through a bottle of this like like
that i mean this is quality stuff bodega
cat
i'm [ __ ] pumped for you guys to try
this it's so it's coming so soon i would
say
hopefully within the month we'll see
you know what really happens here with
this but uh comedy clubs they're gonna
have it theaters uh well we have to get
through legal in certain states like we
have to i mean some apparently new
york's a real [ __ ] to get through yeah
you know
that [ __ ] watch we gotta do something
about that watch gotta figure out the
watch
um it's broken i just watched a
documentary on the guy who invented
rolex very fascinating yeah well we'll
get to that later i just watched the
carlin dock part one and two oh
we gotta talk about that i mean i don't
know how long we're we're going yeah now
we gotta we gotta bounce we gotta run
[ __ ] soon too oh yeah but uh yeah the
carlin dock was uh
was [ __ ] amazing what did you like
about it
i mean look it inspired me to be a
better comic and a worse husband and
father
that uh no he was an incredible comic
and that he was able to reinvent himself
so many times like yeah that he became
corny in the 80s to people like they're
like oh this is he's mocked and then he
used that as fuel and came back stronger
than ever and like 90s carlin's my
favorite carlin i think yeah oh really
yeah probably me too
because he was he was finding himself
and going hard but also staying silly
yeah he was really awesome uh and also
carlin was not personal he was very
society this society that words this
words that this like talk about his wife
his daughter his upbringing the whole
thing so that was fascinating i didn't
know he was kicked out of that he was
kicked out of school high school grade
dropout ninth grade drug really goes to
share of course formal education is
overrated i mean think about some of the
smartest people you know it's like
column coins not for free clickers no i
mean look i guess everything is what you
make of it but all i'm saying is if if
you're a dropout you could still be one
of the smartest [ __ ] people there's
no reflection on intelligence yeah
yeah and just as a comedian and an
artist or whatever you want to call it
he did everything first like i see
comics now doing [ __ ] i'm like carlin
did that 30 years ago 25 years ago
that's how hip it still is i know i know
and there's a reason the right wing the
left wing they all post clips of carlin
because they're like we like him no we
like it but it's just you couldn't put
him in a box you couldn't put him in a
box exactly he was just a comic just
making observations yeah no carlin is uh
we got to get i think we need some
comics we need in this wall who we've
lost we got geraldo norman saggett we
got rodney we need prior carlin joan
rivers patrice patrice let's get some
other
if you want to send stuff in guys uh
how are we going to do that in the
future matt
we'll figure it out can we give the
address gotham studios did you change it
on google all right well there you go
give google uh give that a go gotham
studios new york it's on uh 30 30 51
west 39th there you go that's the 16th
floor don't come by and visit us though
we'll figure this out we might have to
change this did you just say the floor
yeah yeah
i think if they get
i do have those i do have those fears on
stage sometimes i'm like am i going to
die like peter finch in the end of
network
am i going to be mid jokes some dudes
just show up with guns like
yeah it could happen what a way to go
though
i mean [ __ ]
i always wonder like if chappelle got
stabbed god forbid yeah would people
drop the the hate
or would they be like
problematic comedian got stabbed i think
if anyone if that headline formed people
would [ __ ] go nuts i think you can't
that's true i mean
anyone who's okay with violence in
response to jokes is a piece of [ __ ] i
agree
and and dumb and they're not factoring
in something could have horrible could
have happened oh the guy who went at him
had a [ __ ] weapon and he got he's in
jail for life you see that later they
found out he tried to kill a guy
i think he got arrested i don't think
he's in jail for life i didn't see that
i think it's murder
attempted murder
pull it up but yeah either way bodega
cat's coming it's on the way it's it's
in the flesh right here we can touch it
we can drink it so it's just got to get
through this legal [ __ ] stuff yeah but
we're
we just want you all to know this is
this isn't a [ __ ] game no this is
coming hell yeah
thanks chris this is exciting i remember
when that we you know first were talking
about this and now it's like it's a
thing it's i know it's crazy that it's
like a thing you can touch it's pretty
wild and it's so daunting when you start
it like what are we gonna do how are we
gonna do a label how are we gonna try it
how we're gonna taste it but just chip
away slowly and we got there
i think the guy's name is elijah white
elijah
oh
oh boy
terrifying
looks like the grinch
oh my god he does
come on he stole uh he stole the
hollywood ball show he stole comedy
he's charged with attempted murder thank
you wow you're right i don't know if
it's on chappelle or other no another
guy another guy oh from some other guy
who wrote that headline you i know right
nice and vague it's like melanie's old
joke is it the post sounds like somebody
texted you the news
bozo and queens hit lady or something
bozo is such a [ __ ] underrated word
always do bozo bozo such like an old new
york type of word yeah trump would say
bozo
bozo
trump when he's doing [ __ ] like it is
like a comic just trying to figure out a
joke except trump is going for like
cheers right yeah you know what i mean
you see him fishing he's like oh they're
cheering like i'll use that that'll make
the top 45. you know what i mean that'll
be the clip yeah exactly let me should
we do bits before we get out of here
bits i mean you you who needs bits more
than this guy i'm [ __ ] dying bro
yeah the well is dry you got to start
from scratch baby
all right all right i got a couple ideas
here
what do you got for now tell me if this
has been done because it's it's starting
to click on stage it's it's
uh new and still clunky but it's
starting it feels like it's starting to
get momentum
i still think it's weird that we [ __ ]
shame in 2022 like you know we're with
all this progress have you done this one
on the pod before have i done this about
native americans okay no never mind okay
so i think the best time to be a
promiscuous lady was native american
time like inca aztec because they
sacrificed virgins to the gods
so being promiscuous could save your
life you know like uh the chief comes up
he's like hey the crops are dying we got
to sacrifice a virgin are you a virgin
i'd be like
huge [ __ ]
what are you kidding i give the best
arrowhead on this side of the
hoe in navajo and i just i like that
system better they get rid of the boring
gals and we keep the fun ones so now i
got a chief
chief up on the volcano going you should
have [ __ ] me whoa
so you're actually getting penalized for
being a virgin and also are they
sacrificing male virgins ever because
because then you got the angle of the
guy being like but i've been trying oh
that's good
yeah i'll use that i like that the male
virgin yeah
i don't think they care about male
virgins yeah
and yet
the male virgins in this country the
ones uh
angry and killing people they're the
ones sacrificing people yeah exactly
okay
in cells
oh yeah
all right i'm getting too brave
all right i got an idea all right
good good angle good angle here's my
ideas like all right so i think it's
crazy that like you don't realize what
like gambling was illegal
almost everywhere in the country just a
few years ago and now every time you
turn on the tv it's like fanduel uh
draftkings like it's just gambling
non-stop it makes you wonder what's
going to be legal in five years like are
you gonna be watching monday night
football they go to break and it's like
horse horse [ __ ]
you or like you know uh we'll bring the
cocaine
and uh yes and there's some angle i
think could be maybe with like uh ages
17 and up because that's the that's the
age of consent now
right right well we did it with weed too
yeah
and now they're like a lot of i think
san francisco just legalized drugs
because of all the heroin use
but uh that's good that's good what will
be legal
you know one guy i like the guy who's
like come on incest
we got gambling we got weed
pedophilia they start weed in like
portland maybe they start uh incest in
like kentucky
yes yes exactly
you're gambling on having a [ __ ] up
kid
but yeah it's so true like thing we even
did with gay marriage i remember obama
being like gay marriage is immoral or
whatever the hell i'm even thinking then
as a younger guy like that's not gonna
last well some people they'll go to the
supreme court or you know they'll
testify before congress or something
where they'll say you know like we need
to legalize weed you'll get someone but
then no one's going to do that with
incest no one's going to show up like
guys come on like this
it's not a cool thing to push yeah look
at my sister come on man like cheech and
chong want to be the face of weed no one
wants to be the face of incest
you know yes yes that's a bad face
we've all seen that kid
he's uh not looking good but yeah
there's a lot here's something here you
can just make a list of all the things
that are still illegal and just plug
those into commercials yeah
all right yeah weed we're playing guys
i mean i need a new act
scratch-offs were always legal which i
never got cause i'm like isn't that
gambling yeah what the hell is it cause
it's so cheap hold on
he's got something where i was when i
was a kid riverboats were big you
weren't allowed to gamble but you could
have a gambling on incest cruises
okay
go on the boat yeah i [ __ ] my cousin
but it was on it was on the water
all right
in says cruise
i'm telling you
i'm gonna start that myself
a million dollar idea
no but i think yeah i think uh mom i
booked a cruise yeah
give me a minute right
you know people go on uh vacate like
bachelor parties in vegas
bachelor party at the family reunion
i'm hung up on the incest thing
uh should we we should say guys we have
all these cool glasses on we might be
drunk uh is it we might be drunkpod.com
yeah we might be drunkpod.com the
patreon is
patreon.com we might be drunk pod uh
we're growing questions a lot of big
guests coming up yeah mark where are you
gonna be on the road bro i'm all over i
don't know when this comes out sunday
right oh this is okay well uh this
weekend coming up i mean i'm in irvine
california the irvine improv come on out
say hi i i rarely get out to la to do a
full weekend so this will be a banger
and i'm doing the fully loaded tour with
bert he asked me to plug that because
that's like baseball stadiums and uh
race tracks so that's going to be a lot
of tickets and
markdomancomedy.com
uh irvine improv the vogel in red bank
new jersey we just out of the show wise
guys salt lake city houston improv san
antonio lol
uh comedy off broadway in lexington
richmond funny bone west palm beach
uh
all kinds of good stuff boston
uh portland seattle brea you name it so
we're going everywhere we got uh
cleveland ohio houston texas uh
west palm beach buffalo san jose
uh pittsburgh uh dania beach so many
more coming uh i'll be in la irvine all
that [ __ ] soon too i'll be in uh all
over the country so samurail.com shows
love it building a new act yes it's
gonna be awesome that's what i was gonna
say if you're a real comedy fan and you
wanna see
a guy a real comedian working on a new
act this is a cool thing to see it's a
really positive spin on it stop trying
go see this guy bomb all over all over
the country
uh no great to see you guys again miss
you all yeah fantastic great in the
studio
huge guests are coming you're going to
love the huge guests we got great comics
uh carlin coming in and pretty well you
already have watched it but our boy
stove uh
baby stavros halki has his new special's
crushing brushing it's a great special
give it a watch
we love you guys thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]
like a cop's coming and naked samuel is
feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
[Music]